derek shoven is convicted on all charges
president biden and co-president harris
celebrate while nancy pelosi thanks
george floyd for being killed
and the democrats call for tearing down
america's supposedly racist systems i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news and
there's plenty of it this morning
we'll get to it in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that you're
spending way too much
on that cell phone bill like hundreds of
dollars too much every single year
which is why thousands of customers are
canceling the nation's largest wireless
providers why well they found out they
can get the same service at half the
price by switching over to puretalk
that's right instead of charging you
obscene fees to pay for their massive
mainstream media campaigns corporate
campuses retail outlets across the
country
pure talk passes the savings on to you
the average family saves over 800
a year and switching is super easy you
can keep your phone keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids right
now you can get unlimited talk text and
six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month
and here's the thing if you go over on
the data they're not going to charge you
for it you really have nothing to lose
why are you spending money
on unlimited talk texts and unlimited
data and spending hundreds of dollars
too much for that when you could be
getting unlimited talk tax six gigs of
data for 30 bucks a month
and if you go over they're not going to
charge you for it from your cell phones
i'll pound 250 say ben shapiro get
started with my friends at pure talk
usa save fifty percent off your very
first month that is pounds two five zero
say keyword ben shapiro and you get 50
off your very first month of pure talk
coverage again save money on your cell
phone bill pure talk usa pound 250 and
say my name
ben shapiro to get started alrighty so
obviously the massive news of the day is
that late
yesterday afternoon eastern time the
jury came in
with its verdict in the killing of
george floyd
by derek chovin the jury determined that
it was murder
not just second-degree murder it was
second degree murder third degree murder
and manslaughter
according to the jury here was the judge
announcing the jury verdict yesterday
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
either during the above entitled matter
as to count two third degree murder
perpetrating an eminently dangerous act
find the defendant guilty
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count three second degree
manslaughter culpable negligence
creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty okay so those
charges carry
as per the statute 12.5 years for second
degree 12.5 years for third degree
four years for manslaughter if you don't
have a prior conviction
there are some extenuating factors that
the prosecution is going to try to
present to the judge to call for more
than the maximum
sentence allotted by law suggesting that
chovin should spend
presumably decades in prison for the
death of george floyd
so let's talk for a second about the
jury here so the jury
spent about 10 hours in deliberation it
was a three-week trial
they spent about 10 hours deliberating
they came back early yesterday afternoon
like 2 30 eastern time
and it became clear that they were going
to give a verdict so it was pretty
obvious as soon as they announced that
they were coming back that it was going
to be guilty on all charges
uh i said this publicly the reason being
that in minnesota you actually have to
be acquitted by the entire jury or you
have to be convicted by the entire jury
so once the jury said they were coming
back unless they were going to acquit
him on all charges which was
extraordinarily doubtful it was pretty
obvious they were going to convict him
on all charges if they had been a
hang-up
if there had been a couple of jurors who
were not into it then they would have
gone back to the judge they would have
asked questions they would have gone
back to the judge they would have said
you know we can't reach a verdict the
judge would have sent them back he would
have said you need to go back and talk
about it and see if you can reach a
verdict
then into any of that in record time
they came down for the conviction of
derek chovin
in my view of the evidence the jury's
wrong now nothing unique in that
jurors can be wrong sometimes or perhaps
i'm wrong that is possible too but
in my view of the evidence not only is
the jury wrong
given the fact they didn't even ask any
questions of the judge i wonder if they
even
examined the evidence the reason being
the second and third degree murder
charges
it seems unsupportable to me on a
logical level that the second and third
degree murder charges based on what we
saw in the courtroom and the entire
trial was televised
that those charges are justifiable by
the evidence beyond a reasonable doubt
remember the standard
is not by preponderance of the evidence
the standard is not do you think that
chovin is guilty of second and third
degree murder
the the question is do you know beyond a
reasonable doubt that he is guilty of
second and third degree murder
we've walked through these charges many
times third degree murder does not even
apply in this case
originally the judge said that third
degree murder should not be brought as a
charge because it's so-called depraved
heart murder depraved heart murder is
where you shoot a gun into a crowd
the statute specifically says when you
present harm to others
plural right and then you hit one person
you shoot into a crowd you don't have
any specific intent to kill a person
but you know that you probably will kill
somebody that's what a depraved murderer
is that's what third degree murder is
that did not apply in this case they
convicted
uh they convicted chauvin of it anyway
second degree murder they would have had
to find
that felony assault was intended that
chauvin intended to commit a felony
assault not to
participate in a routinely used police
procedure that was greenlit by the
minneapolis police department
but that he intended to commit a felony
assault on george floyd
not that it was an accident not that he
went too far in the process
of of pursuing that but he intended
right felony assault is an intent crime
that he intended to commit a felony
assault and in the process of that
felony assault
george floyd died the the sort of
criminal equivalent
would be somebody who's robbing a bank
they intend to commit a felony
somebody else gets shot during the
process of robbing the bank by accident
that's felony murder
okay very difficult to prove the jury
went for that as well manslaughter i
said all along
was the easiest charge to prove because
all you had to prove there was
recklessness
and there the prosecution made a fairly
compelling case because the prosecution
said
that in that particular case derek
chovin
could have seen that floyd was dying
under his knee and therefore he should
have turned floyd over
he should have given him medical care
right all of that is a lot more arguable
and at least a lot more evidentiarily
based than the second and third degree
murder charges but the jury not only
went for the second and third degree
murder charges they went for it in
record time they went right for it like
very very quickly
which suggests to me that they didn't
really take a fulsome look of the
evidence
now maybe they did and maybe they just
came to a different conclusion but
the presumption has to be that this was
the most highly watched trial
in modern american history yeah the
president of the united states
sounding off about it you had
congresswoman maxine waters outside the
courtroom
who was saying that there were going to
be riots in the streets essentially if
they didn't get the verdict they wanted
he had the entire media declaring the
entire media
to a man declaring that this trial was a
foregone conclusion and not just a
foregone conclusion but that it was
insulting to even have to watch the
defense put on a case
the notion that the pressure campaign
brought to bear over the course of the
last year to convict chauvin had
no impact on the jury here beggars the
imagination
it just i find it very very difficult to
believe that this was in fact an
objective pursuit
of the system of justice now perhaps it
was
perhaps it was okay perhaps the jury
just went in the room and they did their
best
and they came away after having examined
all three weeks of the evidence and they
ignored the fact that george floyd had
three times a deadly level of fentanyl
in a system and they ignored the fact
that
he had a 75 arterial blockage and they
ignored the fact that he said he
couldn't breathe before he was on the
ground and they ignored the fact that he
was resisting arrest
they ignored the fact that he asked to
be taken out of the car and to be put on
the ground they ignored the fact that he
was actively talking
just before he died which shows that his
airway was not obstructed they ignored
the autopsy results that showed that he
had many drugs in his system and not
just that he had many drugs in his
system but no damage to his trachea and
no damage to his
and no damage to his the arteries on
either side of his neck
right perhaps they looked at all of that
and they said you know what we just
agree with dr
dr tobin who is the prosecution medical
witness
and we just agree with him and we
believe that just by looking at the tape
he could magically determine the cause
of death on george floyd and that it was
only
derek chovan's knee not even on his neck
on his upper back
that caused the death of george fled
maybe that maybe they did their job and
they did it beautifully
but there is one thing that the jury
didn't do there was one charge
that the jury never even considered
there was one charge that was never even
alleged
that chovin was convicted of and that of
course is the biggest charge of all
not the murder charge the charge that
derek chauvin
is emblematic of an american system of
racism
that charge was never proved no evidence
was brought to that idea
there was no there was not even an
allegation that this killing
was racial in any way that allegation
never was brought to court
there was no evidence presented of that
allegation
and yet that was the entire story if you
ask americans today
is derek chovan a racist i guarantee you
a majority of americans will say yes
and to what is the evidence of that that
george floyd died
that is not evidence of racism that's
evidence at best
of a bad cop it is evidence of bad
police procedure
it is evidence of recklessness that is
not evidence of racism but we all know
that the real charge that was brought
against derek chovin because it was
being brought against america more
broadly is that america is racist and
this case
is emblematic of that this data point is
all about america being racist
he was never charged with that he was
never accused of that no evidence was
brought of that
but not only was he convicted of that
the entire country the entire country
was convicted of a crime
that was that there was literally no
evidence presented of
and that really is the part that that is
is terrible for the country
and has driven the narrative all along
because let us be real about this
if the if the body cam footage had
broken
at the time when it was supposed to by
the way the body cam footage broke well
after the original third-party footage
of what was going on with chauvin and
floyd if the body cam footage had broken
and the third party footage had broken
and all of the evidence
had been cast into the public sphere if
all of that had happened
and there had not been 20 million people
in the streets declaring that america
was systemically racist
and that this case was a case of racism
it is highly doubtful to me whether a
jury would have convicted of second and
third degree murder on this evidence
which suggests to me of course that when
it comes to due process
this was due process in name
it was not justice in effect because
individual justice relies on you
evaluating the evidence before you
not on bringing in preconceived notions
about systemic american racism that were
never alleged in the courtroom the
prosecution
did not allege that the prosecution did
not allege that chovan was a racist who
went to kill a black man that day
that was not alleged the prosecution did
not allege that chauvin killed floyd
because he was black
or even that he was reckless because he
was black the prosecution did not allege
racism but that is what chovin stands
convicted of
for the rest of his life that's what
america stands convicted of in the view
of the entire media
in the view of the entire democratic
party this was eminently political from
beginning
to end from beginning to end so when i
say that the jury is wrong
juries get it wrong but the question
isn't whether the jury got it wrong the
question is whether the jury got it
wrong
because they were actually convicting
chauvin of a crime that he was not even
alleged to have committed
which is standing in for america's evil
racist system
and the answer there is pretty obviously
yes
okay and you can see it in every element
of the narrative that's been trotted out
every single element of the narrative
for example felonies floyd who is a
relative that george floyd's
brother got up and suggested standing
next to al sharpton one of the great
race baiters in american history and
jesse jackson another one of the
greatest race baiters in america
american history and benjamin crump
another great race baiter in modern
american history
felonies floyd stood there and suggested
that george
george floyd was like emmett's till and
now for those who don't know about the
emmett till crime one of the great
racial crimes in american history emmett
till was a 14 year old black boy
who was falsely accused of having
sexually harassed
a white woman the white woman's family
then went to
the place where emantel lived dragged
him out of his house shot him and threw
him in a river
in other words the circumstances
surrounding george floyd's death are
nothing
like the circumstances surrounding
emmett till's death which was a purely
racist murder
in the south in the jim crow era but
this is the comparison that was made
continuously and repeatedly
is that every day america's racist
system is creating
new emmett tills and george floyd is
just the latest example of this
here is felonies floyd making that case
the person that comes to my mind
is 1955 and to me he was the first
george floyd
that was that was immature wow
wow i did uh
was on cnn with deborah watts
and she just brought him back to life
people forgot about him yeah but
he was the first george floyd okay that
is a that is a
lie it is a by the way it is a slanderer
against emmett hill
who is not in fact a repeat criminal who
had held up a pregnant woman at gunpoint
and robbed her house
with her kid in the house he was not a
repeat drug offender who done jail time
he was not a person passing counterfeit
bills emmett till he was not somebody
who resisted arrest
he was not any of those things emmett
till was killed because he was a black
because he was a black boy living in the
jim crow segregated south and there were
white races who murdered him
there's no similarity between the emmett
till case and the george floyd case but
again that is what chauvin was convicted
of yesterday
not just in the court of law but in the
court of public opinion which in america
matters a hell of a lot more
than the court of law and it's not just
chauvin who stands convicted of that of
course the idea from the entire
democratic party and the media is that's
the entire country that stands convicted
of that when it was not
even alleged based on evidence it was
not even alleged
and it seems to me that what happened
really here is that the jury took
allegations that were not even made and
then read them into the crime
derek chovin had to be convicted of
second and third degree murder not
because the fact pattern supported
second and third degree murder might
have supported manslaughter but he had
to be convicted of second and third
degree murder
or whatever charges they threw at him
frankly because he was a stand-in for
the evil history of american racism
and the current system of american
racial prejudice of american white
supremacy
and that to me does not look very much
like a justice system that does not look
like a justice system designed to
achieve individual justice it looks like
social justice and racial justice
projected
into a case where the evidence didn't
fit but it didn't matter
in just a second we'll get to the
reaction from the politician
and media that prove exactly what i'm
saying
i mean it is it is pretty astonishing
the reaction to this has been quite
amazing
and and quite telling we'll get to more
of this in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that you need
to make your business better you do and
the best way to make sure that your
business is doing well
is to market it properly well a lot of
people are still putting out their
things like phone numbers
people are still trying cold call people
using email these are old-fashioned ways
of reaching your customers instead what
you need is to get on text
seriously i don't respond to cold calls
on phones i'll just let it go to
voicemail or i'll just you know
hit end but if somebody texts there's a
good chat i'm going to see the text
podium is the messaging platform to
power your business it helps you reach
your customers wherever they are
business messaging with podium helps you
gain reviews collect payments
communicate with customers and capture
leads
all from a single inbox podium helps you
adapt to the changing customer
expectations
you have to take my word for it rpm
alamo increased business by 20
tony is the owner of rpm alamo he said
we've generated more revenue decreased
vacancy rates and pulled in more leads
than we could have in multiple years
that's priceless america's car mark
collected 21 000 leads
through webchat tj who helps run the
digital experience in america's carmart
said before podium we had a contact us
for him
it could have been days before anybody
got back to that customer our response
time has now been cut down
two minutes find out how podium can help
your business reach more customers today
get started free today at podium.com
shapiro that's dot com slash shapiro
again podium.com
shapiro okay so you can see how the
media and our politicians react and they
are reacting
not to the conviction of a cop on
evidence presented
that he was reckless or even that he
committed murder because he was brutal
they reacted to this on the basis of the
racial question that was not
even alleged at trial and to which no
evidence was presented
there is not a jot or tittle of evidence
that has been presented to suggest
that if george floyd had been a white
man who was and the police were called
to the scene of a crime
for a white guy who had a long uh a rap
sheet as long as your arm and the white
guy were high on fentanyl three times
the legal limit resisting arrest
begging to be put on the ground that
that white guy would have lived under
the exact same circumstances
in which we saw this case that was not
even presented there's no evidence
presented to that they didn't bring a
facebook post from chauvin they didn't
bring any evidence of chauvin's intent
they didn't bring any
any evidence that chauvin was in fact a
racist it does not matter that is what
america and chauvin
stand convicted of today and
and the way that the media treat this
and the way the politicians treat that's
perfectly obvious so nancy pelosi
gave what i thought was maybe the single
most egregious statement
on not just a criminal trial but on the
death of a human being that i have heard
in quite some time
her take on george floyd's death is
malevolent i mean truly malevolent here
is nancy pelosi talking about the death
of george floyd who remember
did not willingly go to his death
because he was making some sort of
greater sacrifice
even if you believe the jury he was
killed
that he did not want to die nor should
he have wanted to die
but nancy pelosi thanked him for his
death
she thanked him for his here's nancy
pelosi
thank you george floyd for sacrificing
your life for justice
for being there to call out to your mom
how how heartbreaking was that call out
for your mom
i can't breathe but because of you and
because of
thousands millions of people around the
world who came out
for justice your name will always be
synonymous
with justice okay forget for a second
about the beginning of the statement in
which she thanks a man for dying
which is just an astonishing breach of
decency
i mean somebody gets shot by the cops
even if they're shot and they deserve to
be shot
you don't thank them for their death
that is a that is a bizarre bizarre take
at best but her her statement
that that she on the day of chauvin's
conviction
that because floyd died and millions of
people went out in the streets
basically children was convicted because
of that is itself an admission
that this trial outcome was seen as the
predictable outcome not of the evidence
but of all of the surrounding hubbub
regarding george floyd and the blm
movement of last summer and the 20
million people in the streets
which is to say that it was not a pure
jury case examining the evidence looking
at the looking at what happened
it was in fact outside pressure that
made a fair bit of difference
and all this ties in to get the broader
american narrative which is that all of
this is about america's racist systems
so for example you have the minneapolis
mayor jacob frye who is just a
a a moral idiot of extraordinary
proportions
jacob fry the same guy who went and got
shellacked last summer he went down to a
blm rally tried to sympathize with them
and they said what are you doing here
well they started yelling at him for
being a white supremacist
because when you show your neck to to a
mob of people who wish to tear down the
system and you're a member of the system
it never goes well for you
but jacob fry tweeted this out george
floyd came to minneapolis to better his
life
okay that is at best on the record
debatable considering that he was
in a car doing heavy doses of drugs and
passing counterfeit bills
after having committed many many crimes
but ultimately his life will have
bettered our city
the jury joined in a shared conviction
that has animated minneapolis for the
last 11 months they refused to look away
and affirmed he should still be here
today
i think everybody agrees that george
floyd shouldn't have died
there's no debate about that but the
notion that this has bettered
minneapolis in some way
is indicative of a basic democratic case
which is that the world has gotten
better over the course of the last year
because of this mass movement in the
streets and i'm just wondering what the
evidence is
for that i'm wondering what the evidence
is that the world has gotten better
because of what has happened over the
course of the last year
in terms of the supposed racial
awakening in the united states you have
the same thing from
minnesota a.g keith ellison he said this
isn't justice
it's accountability now what you notice
here is the reason he's saying that it's
not justice is because the idea
that democrats are going to push forward
and this is the next move right is that
it was never about this particular case
it's about the broader system you'll
notice the language that is being used
by by the left today by members of the
media by
members of the democratic party is not
the system worked
usually in the aftermath of a criminal
conviction the line that you hear very
often from politicians in the media is
yes the system worked you're not hearing
that today
you're really not hearing that today but
instead what you're hearing is justice
was done there's a
major philosophical difference between
justice was done and the system worked
if you say the system works you're
providing legitimacy to the system
life doesn't want to provide legitimacy
to the system remember remember the
system
is racist remember the system is bigoted
remember the system is the bad guy
derek shoving isn't even the bad guy
derek shoving is just the outgrowth of
the system
in a certain way a lot of folks on the
left don't even believe that derek
chovan is responsible for his own
actions because they didn't prove that
he was a racist he's just the outgrowth
of a systemically racist system
he's just a widget in the system the
system is bad so they're not saying the
system worked
because that would be lending gravitas
and legitimacy to a system they hate
instead its justice was done when they
say justice was done what they mean is
we got what we wanted
okay so here is minnesota a.g keith
ellison saying it's not about justice
it's about accountability because
broader justice of course means that you
tear down the entire system
i would not call today's verdict justice
however
because justice implies true restoration
but
it is accountability which is the first
step towards justice
and now the cause of justice is in your
hands
and when i say your hands i mean the
hands of the people of the united states
there we go
there we go because the entire system
has to be torn down right
that's the next step the next step is
that this was this was merely indicative
of a broader that was not even a charge
that was evidenced
it was not a charge brought again
chauvin but children's gonna go to jail
for that charge his life will be ruined
for that charge
i'm not saying he shouldn't go to jail
maybe he should for manslaughter
maybe the jury even had a legitimate
belief in second and third degree
but that is not why the media and the
democrats are convicting chauvin today
the reason that they are convicting
children today is not on the basis of
the evidence it's on the basis of facts
not in evidence namely that chovin was
the racist outgrowth of a racist system
which is why this is a national story as
opposed to a local crime story in the
first place
now just a second i want to ask a pretty
easy question which is
okay so is this hope have things gotten
better
because the basic idea is that things
are now about to get better for black
americans in the united states
the answer pretty obviously is no things
are not about to get better in the
united states for black americans
many more black americans will die
because of the approach of the media and
the democratic party with regard to
policing
period end of story okay so let's take a
look at what's happened over the course
of the past year
we've been told that the great racial
awakening brought about by george
floyd's death has been a boon to the
united states
we've seen nancy pelosi on tape thanking
george floyd for his death in a bizarre
show
of misplacement i mean my goodness what
a what a tone-deaf thing to say
that this has made america better in
some way and particularly for black
americans there's an entire piece from
the associated press today
titled floyd verdict gives hope if only
fleeting
to black america by the way that's not
an op-ed that is a news piece because
our media are fully invested in the idea
that all the systems of the united
states are deeply racist
and that only if shroven was convicted
would we be on the road to recovery
here is the associated press in a news
story remember not an op-ed relief
even if fleeting and momentary is a
feeling that black americans have rarely
known in america
from slavery and jim crow segregation to
enduring punishments for living while
black
a breath of fresh air untainted by
oppression has long been hard to come by
that's a news story gang your media are
hot garbage
your establishment media delinda asked
they do not have the interest of the
american people at heart they do have
the interest
of american ideals at heart they don't
have the the ideas martin luther king jr
at heart they have divisiveness
and polarization and violence at heart i
mean this is bad stuff
the notion that all black americans are
living under the constant threat of
extermination
is now being reported as objective news
by the associated press
nonetheless as the ap the conviction of
ex-cop derek chauvin from murdering
george floyd nearly a year ago allowed
many across this city
and the nation to pent to exhale pent up
anxiety and to inhale a sense of hope
but what might they hope for the fate of
chauvin
showed black americans and their
compatriots once again that the legal
system is capable of valuing black lives
well the system is capable of valuing
black lives but what you're calling for
in terms of changes to the system
devalues black lives as we'll talk about
in just one second or at least it can
hold one white police officer in
minnesota accountable for what many
declared an unambiguous act of murder
months ago yeah just because many
declared something an unambiguous act of
murder means nothing
today you'll notice that there are many
in the media who are attempting to
declare an
unambiguous act of murder that a police
officer in columbus ohio
shot a girl a a 15 year old black girl
then the police released the footage and
it turns out the 15 year old black girl
was trying to stab another
black woman with a knife when she was
shot
okay but again the facts are getting in
the way of a good narrative here
this may be the beginning of the
restoration of believing that a justice
system can work said civil rights leader
martin luther king
iii but we have to constantly stay on
the battlefield in a peaceful and
non-violent way and make demands
this has been going on for years and one
case one verdict does not change how
systemic racism has worked in our system
right the systems
have to be torn down what the media are
calling for
is not renewed faith in the system what
they are calling for is continuous
pressure on the system see
here's the bizarre nature of the only
thing that changed yesterday because
chauvin was convicted as opposed to
acquitted
is that there weren't riots because for
the left the outcome really didn't
change
right for the left it doesn't matter
what the what the
antecedent was the consequent was always
going to be the same in the if
then statement it did not matter what
what you said in the if the then was
always going to be the same
if shown had been acquitted then the
then they would have said this
because derek chovin was acquitted this
just shows that the american racial
the american justice system is racially
malevolent that america is a deeply
systemically racist place
and this requires therefore this
requires that you give us inordinate
power to reshape all the systems of
american life
so as to achieve racial equity okay that
was version number one where chauvinism
is acquitted
when children was convicted here's the
argument today derek chovin was
convicted
and this is just the first step to
realizing that you have to give us more
power so we can reshape the systems of
american power
in line with providing greater racial
equity it does not matter whether shogun
was convicted or not for purposes of the
agenda
in fact it seems that there are at least
a few in the media who are kind of
unhappy that chauvin was convicted
because it seems to grant a certain
legitimacy to a justice system they
really really dislike
i mean to take one example msnbc's jason
johnson seemed pretty pissed at the
verdict yesterday he was
instead of he said i'm not going to
celebrate this verdict because it gives
legitimacy to a system that's bad
i actually always thought that he would
be found guilty because it's sort of a
cultural makeup call
but i'm not happy i'm not pleased i
don't have any sense of satisfaction i
don't think this is a system working
i don't think this is a good thing what
this says to me
is that in order to get a nominal degree
of justice in this country
that a black man has to be murdered on
air viewed by the entire world there
have to be a year's worth of protests
and a phalanx of other white police
officers to tell one white officer that
he was wrong
in order to get one scintilla of justice
okay that last point there is him
admitting
that the jury was pressured by the by
the millions of people in the streets
which
of course is true and perfectly obvious
to anyone with a shred of common sense
and he says
in order to get this conviction you
needed millions of people in the streets
okay there's a word for that and it's
mob justice okay there's a term for that
and this is not a fringe viewpoint jason
johnson's viewpoint
in fact you get the viewpoint right
because the idea is if the system is bad
then anything that justifies the system
may not be that great aoc the
irrepressible
brilliant so fresh so face
the face of justice in america alexander
ocasio-cortez who spent tens of
thousands of dollars on private security
over the course of the last few months
but you should definitely defund the
police
aoc said that this verdict should not be
a ray of hope it should just be a
reminder that we need to completely
change the systems of american life
it's not justice and i'll explain to you
why it's not justice
it's not justice because justice
is george floyd going home tonight
to be with his family justice
is adam toledo
getting tucked in by his mom tonight
justice is
when you're pulled over they're not
being
a gun that's part of that interaction
because you have a headlight out right
all justice is
tearing down all the systems and you'll
notice the facts don't matter in any of
these cases
the adam toledo shoot was a justifiable
shooting by a police officer adam toledo
was missing for two days in chicago his
mom didn't even call the cops
he was a member of a gang where were his
parents his mom tucking him in
she did not call the cops when he went
missing for two nights he was shooting a
gun
and moving vehicles when the police were
called to the scene he ran from the cops
he had a gun behind him and as he
dropped the gun he was shot
okay then and for her justice is that he
goes home
justice says that george floyd in other
words justice is
the tearing down of all of the systems
because any bad thing that happens can
be attributed to the system so this
wasn't justice
right justice is bad things don't happen
anymore and bad things won't happen
anymore
justified or unjustified bad things will
never happen anymore if you just tear
down the systems
that is the goal here van jones on cnn
doing the same routine right this just
shows
one down but there are many more to go
because the system is still corrupt the
system is still bad
that's the generalized point here this
is not the end of anything
this is the beginning of something where
is congress they need to act those
chokeholds are still legal
according to federal government that
needs to change uh there's no duty to
intervene from the federal government
that needs to change
uh there's no registry for cops like
chauvin that needs to change
you know when you have somebody like you
know uh representative karen bass and
and tim scott fighting we need to get
behind them this should never happen
again
one down many more to go by the way i
noticed that it was the democrats who
filibustered tim scott's police reform
bill last year because tim scott happens
to be
a republican reverend al sharpton who to
my amazement and astonishment remains
a major figure in american public life
despite being involved in the incitement
of two
separate racial conflagrations one in
crown heights
and another freddie's fashion mart and
who's been wrong on nearly every major
racial issue and runs a shakedown
network designed
at getting businesses to pay money to
his network so that he will leave them
alone
al sharpton still considered a face of
racial justice after the tuwana browley
scandal
it's just unbelievable to me here's al
sharpton saying the war and the fight
isn't over again because it was never
directed it was never about this one
case
you understand the entire contention was
that it was about the system
doesn't matter that they never showed it
was the system they never showed
that that derek jovan was a racist again
it's this is the key point
they keep they're convicting the entire
system and chauvin of a crime they did
not even allege with evidence against
chauvin or really the system
here's sharpton pushing it we don't find
pleasure in this we don't celebrate a
man going to jail
we would have rather george be alive
amen
but we celebrate that we
because young people white and black
some castigated many that are here
tonight marched
and kept marching yeah and kept going
many of them looked down on but they
kept marching
and wouldn't let this die and this is
an assurance to them that if we don't
give up
that we can win some rounds but the war
and the fight is not it's unbelievable
sharpton is openly admitting he's openly
saying that this was jury tampering
essentially right that if there hadn't
been millions of people in the streets
chovin doesn't get convicted he's saying
it straight out
he's saying that straight out and
already there's a question as to whether
on appeal the conviction is going to be
vacated because
of all of the outside pressure including
from maxine waters it would take a
court of appeals of of a certain level
of courage that i don't think is going
to be apparent
to actually do that but it's it's it's
not as though anybody is is under the
misimpression the public pressure didn't
have anything to do with this verdict
if you're under that misimpression i'm i
point you to al sharpton who thinks
differently
okay here here's the question and what
we're going to get to to this in just
one second
here's the question does this is the
desire to tear down the system is that
making life better for americans
is it making life better for americans
so yesterday in the aftermath of this
individual criminal justice case that
took place in minneapolis
the president of the united states and
co-presidents of the united states joe
biden
and kamala harris spoke that in and of
itself is astonishing
that in the aftermath of a of a criminal
conviction of a single cop
for a murder charge controversial murder
charge
in in an incident in a locale
the president of the united states is
nationalizing the message
the reason he's nationalizing the
message is because always and forever
this was part of a narrative which is
why it was a national story as opposed
to a local crime story as i've discussed
before
the way the media work if a story fits
the narrative they're pushing it becomes
a national story
if a story does not fit the story they
are pushing then it becomes a local
crime story when kermit gosnell murders
babies after they're born
by the dozens that is a local crime
story when george floyd dies
under derrick chauvin's knee that is a
national news story
the way they determine which is which is
simply by determining whether it fits
the narrative they are attempting to
push at any given moment
how strong is the narrator of push the
president of the united states of the
entire united states
black white and green the president of
the united states and the co-president
kamala harris
first of all is super bizarre that joe
biden constantly trots out kamala harris
next to him
basically declaring her the heir right
if i plot
she's here that in and of itself is
weird you would never have seen this
from
from trump you never would have seen
this from obama with biden you think
obama would let biden anywhere within 30
feet of a microphone
for a speech like this so that's weird
just politically
but the reason that the president is
speaking out about this is because the
narrative
must be pushed the narrative must be
pushed we're going to harris and biden
in one second
first let's talk about making your
business better if you're looking to
make your business stronger if you're a
business owner who's hiring you'll
probably face a lot of challenges when
it comes to finding the right person for
your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack sure you
can post your job at some job board but
then all you can do is hope the right
person comes along which is why you
should try zip recruiter for free
at ziprecruiter.com dailywire when you
post a job on zip recruiter it gets sent
out to over 100 top job sites with one
click
then zip recruiter's matching technology
finds people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact zip recruiter is so effective that
four out of five employers who post
unzip recruiter get a quality candidate
within
the very first day it's no wonder over
2.3 million businesses have come to zip
recruiter for their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm you
with way too many options zip recruiter
finds what you are looking for the
needle
in the haystack right now you can try
zip recruiter for free at this web
address
ziprecruiter.com dailywire once again
remember ziprecruiter.com
make your business better by getting the
best employees and if you're an employee
you're looking for a job check out
ziprecruiter as well zip recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire
zippercrew.com
dailywire already we're going to get to
co-president harris and president joe
biden in just
one second and we're going to ask the
question if all of this is supposed to
make the system better
then why are so many more black
americans dying we'll get to that in
just one second first
it's almost time for another new episode
of candace this week's special guest
dana white president of the ultimate
fighting championship
it's the largest mixed martial arts
organization on planet earth the show
streams on fridays at 9 pm eastern 8 pm
central only on dailywear.com
you can get 25 off a new membership with
code candace and get the audio podcast
candace on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to your podcast so
if you need some candid tones in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
all righty so last night the
co-president of the united states and
the president of the united states come
out and speak on an individual local
crime story that is a national story
only because democrats have somehow
twisted this
in defending the narrative that
america's justice system is entirely
racist they use the term systemic racism
because it means everything and nothing
systemic racism means that you don't
actually have to show that derek chovin
was a racist you can say he was the
outgrowth of a systemically racist
system
it also means that you don't actually
have to show any discrepancy between the
arrest statistics and the report
statistics in order for you to clear
the system racist everything is racist
and nothing is racist at the same time
it is a deliberate mush term in order to
be able to implicate a system in evil
without actually explaining how the evil
is predicated in any case
kamala harris comes out the black vice
president of the united states to
declare that america is deeply evil and
racist
here she was yesterday today we feel
a sigh of relief still
it cannot take away the pain a measure
of justice
isn't the same as equal justice
this verdict brings us a step closer
and the fact is we still have work to do
a measure of justice isn't the same as
equal justice right the idea is
that even though we got what we wanted
in this particular trial that doesn't
justify the entire system the entire
system is still broken
not only is the entire system still
broken says kamala harris the black vice
president of the united states
in a racist deeply deeply racist country
not only that
but what we are seeing today in terms of
america's systems is exactly the same as
what we saw in the jim crow era
which is weird because i don't remember
a black vice president of the united
states during the jim crow era or a
two-term black president of the united
states
or you know a black attorney general or
under barack obama
or black supreme court just like there
are a few differences but according to
kamala harris nope
america has a long history of systemic
racism
black americans and black men in
particular have been treated
throughout the course of our history as
less than human
because of smartphones so many americans
have now
seen the racial injustice that black
americans have known for generations
the racial injustice that we have fought
for generations okay so the basic idea
is that nothing has changed
nothing has changed now when she says
systemic racism in order to say that
nothing has changed you have to ignore
the fact that slavery was legal in the
united states
until the 13th amendment to the
constitution
that jim crow was legal in the united
states until the civil rights act in
1965.
that's actual systemic racism you know
in law in order for you to say that
nothing has changed
you have to be utterly blind to reality
in every possible way but that's exactly
what she's saying
and of course it'll make america better
if we all just say this over and over
and over
then joe biden gets to the microphone he
says exactly the same sort of stuff
now we all knew what biden wanted before
the verdict came down right he said that
he wanted
the right verdict he didn't say the
system is supposed to work how the
system works it's not my job to weigh in
on this which is what a normal president
would say
somebody who wanted to turn down the
temperature instead he turned up the
temperature by saying in the middle of
the jury deliberations that he wants the
right verdict to happen
pretty obviously he wanted children
convicted they're a good family
and they're called for peace
and tranquility no matter what that
verdict is
i'm praying the verdict is the right
verdict which is i think it's
overwhelming in my view
i wouldn't say that unless the the jury
was sequestered now
oh i'm sure that now they've been
sequestered everything's fine so we just
talked to
i want to know how they were doing don't
worry the outside pressure had nothing
to do with the jury verdict here
at all at all okay then joe biden gave a
speech last night so that was before the
trial right so we know what he wanted
before before the actual outcome he
could have just waited a few hours
but he didn't then the outcome came
and he just makes accusations that are
not even
alleged in the crime here he was
suggesting not only that this was murder
but that it ripped off the lid of the
systemic racism in our system by the way
isn't there sort of a contradiction
between i'm the head of the system and
also the system is systemically racist
this dude has been a member of the us
government since he was 30 years old he
is now 178 years old
joe biden has been in congress he has
been in positions of public power
at least a decade longer than i have
been alive and yet joe biden is there
part of the system but the system is
racist
and it was exposed to the light of day
and again has
not one scintilla of evidence has been
provided that the chauvin killing
was in fact racist does not matter
here's joe biden pushing this lie anyway
it was a murder in the full light of day
and it ripped the blinders off for the
whole world to see
the systemic racism the vice president
just referred to
there were systemic reasons that's a
stain on our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
profound fear and trauma the pain the
exhaustion
and black and brown america's experience
biden is a predatory politician
okay this is empathy uh th this is this
is
this is policy that is going to get
black people killed in the guise of
empathy what he's pushing right now
because what he's
suggesting of course is a complete
crackdown on policing across the country
because of course
if derek shovin there's no evidence of
his racism then we can only attribute
racism to the entire system
and says joe biden this is the message
take away message from the media and the
democrats is
we can't stop here we can't stop here
there must be more
we can't stop here in order to deliver
real change and reform we can and we
must
do more to reduce the likelihood that
tragedy like this will ever happen and
occur again
to ensure the black and brown people or
anyone
so they don't fear the interactions with
law enforcement
that they don't have to wake up knowing
that they can lose their very life in
the course of just living their life
they don't have to worry about whether
their sons or daughters
will come home after a grocery store run
or just walking down the street or
driving the car or playing in the park
or just sleeping at home he's such a
damned liar black americans
should not be living in fear that they
are just going to be gunned down on the
street by cops
that is utterly unsupportable by any
evidence whatsoever
the number of unarmed black people shot
and killed by the police in the united
states every year is less than 20 and in
many of those cases
we're talking about suspects who are
participating in criminal activity that
is still dangerous to others
the notion that every black american
ought to be living in moral fear of the
cops
is a lie promulgated by politicians for
their own systemic gain
for their for their centralization of
power joe biden is a cynic
he's a cynical politician who wants
centralization of power under his own
auspices and he will lie
to black americans and to white
americans alike in order to get it by
saying that america is deeply racist
and this giant crisis of racism this
public health emergency as
fauci has said as all the members of the
government have said this giant
public health emergency this giant
emergency that tears the soul of america
can only be solved by this daughtering
old white man who's half senile
fixing the system from the inside he
says
the entire system is thoroughly going
racist
he says we have to acknowledge it and we
have to confront it if there are
consequences to the kind of stuff he's
proposing
it ain't gonna be pretty here is joe
biden
and this takes acknowledging and
confronting head-on
systemic racism and the racial
disparities that exist in policing and
in our criminal justice system more
broadly
you know state and local government and
law enforcement
needs to step up but so does the federal
government
yes more power to the federal government
weird you know just as every
outcome in any if-then statement for
democrats is the system
the systemic racism of the united states
needs to be torn down
there's another statement that goes
right along with that one which is give
us more power
which is what joe biden wants so what
are the effects of this power bin
what are the effects been of the black
lives matter protest well we have some
studies on this
one study from travis campbell a phd
student in economics at the university
of massachusetts amherst
showed that thanks to the blm protest
from 2014 to 2019 this doesn't even
include the massive murder uptick in
america's major cities
30 uptick in murder in america's major
cities in 2020
from 2014 to 2019 a 15 to 20
reduction in lethal use of force by
police officers roughly 300 fewer police
homicides
somewhere between 1 000 and 6 000 more
homicides than would have occurred
you know who's going to pay the price
for getting rid of the cops
the people who live in these cities the
predictable outcome of all of this is
going to be police officers resigned
from the force
nobody signs up for the police forces
the police officers who are there simply
avoid
actually going to the scenes of crimes
because they know that their lives will
be ruined even if they do the right
thing let alone if they do the wrong
thing
you are about to watch a collapse of
policing in america's major cities you
know it is the price for that not joe
biden not kamala harris
not anybody on cnn the people who pay
the price for that
are all the people who live in these
cities as businesses leave
as the tax base erodes as public
services get worse
as taxes are increased to compensate and
more businesses leave
as the police simply stop operating
we're about to watch america's major
cities turn into detroit that's what
we're about to watch
that has nothing to do with race that
has to do with crappy policy
we're about to watch an emptying out of
america's biggest cities
because if you're a police officer today
and you're watching
the real the real-time notion that the
facts don't matter in each individual
case the only thing that matters is how
it fits into the
democrat and media scheme of narrative
justice about
race in america why in the world
wouldn't you take that early pension and
get the hell out
why in the world would you be proactive
in your policing
there will be effects of this but it
ain't gonna be good for anybody
the notion that america has gotten
better in any way over the last year i
i defy you to show me a statistic
demonstrating a piece of actual data
demonstrating that the situation around
race in america has improved over the
course of the last year
or little i mean or frankly over the
course of the past 10 years
very difficult to find any data to that
effect because it's not improving it's
getting significantly worse and it's
getting significantly worse
because everything must fit into the
democratic narrative and it is a lie
that america is systemically racist all
of our institutions are shot through
with racism
those systems must be torn down
and if and if and every data point will
be used as an indicator every individual
every individual story will be twisted
and turned until it fits a narrative
that really is not even alleged
there are consequences to this joe biden
ain't going to feel him tamil harris
isn't going to feel him
l sharpton won't feel it van jones won't
feel it none of the people
aoc won't feel it none of these people
are going to feel it
everyday american citizens particularly
living in america's biggest cities are
feeling it already and they're going to
feel it a lot harder in the years to
come
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime go check out the michael
moles show he discusses more on the
chauvin verdict that episode is
available right now i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
bourne
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam scievents audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
the george floyd jurors save themselves
the president and joe biden celebrate
the verdict
and more drag bar perverts throw money
at kids check it out on the michael
knowles show